you look younger on my podcast
you think a hundred percent you look
younger here you right now because
you're around like age people so
you just look good you know what i mean
38 38 39
yeah yeah he's like 40 marks but you're
looking young 30s now but when we were
on your podcast
what was going on
yo dude it was crazy out there it's
confused i think my skin's ashy are out
there no it's not that oh it's the
animals it's the house it's the vibe
everything about it is like it's time to
die
you have all your animals you have like
you keep you go look out that way
there's nobody there you're like what is
this a burial ground
what are we preparing for right i'm
literally out to pasture
send myself out i'll just show myself
out but here you're looking so young
you're so vibrant and everything is
going on you like don't have blue hair
anymore you also don't know how to take
compliments that's another thing
well because i watch it
lots of spices
that's from schulte
hey you look less shitty
you look like [ __ ] in your own home and
then you come here once every six years
and looked better
for sure
ever said to me let me have it no but i
think that we should work on this this
is a good idea i'm going to give you a
real compliment okay and then you don't
even your face right here oh yeah your
face is doing it your face is going like
this
botox it's moving now isn't it
okay
just just take it and know that it's
real and know that you you
know this is so
[ __ ]
comedians cannot be compliments
we love
[Music]
everything is like a high position a
pointing down just trying to give you
covenant okay um do you remember how
don't change the subject let him
compliment you the way i told him to
propose to his wife was so [ __ ]
sociopathic and you pointed it out to me
i was like you know what you should do
this was crazy wasn't this what i said
why she's sleeping you should uh put it
on her finger while she's sleeping
she'll wake up and see it yeah and i was
like oh the rapiest way
like just removing consent completely
from a woman you're married now wake up
you said yes in your sleep
you don't want to give her the option
that's where you come from you're like
that's the way i can do it romantic but
i'm really forcing you into my life
forever i just tried to figure out a way
to do it that took out the eye contact
yes remember when you were engaged and
then you realized that that was a
horrible idea
yes
that's not a compliment i do
that was a compliment
but i do know why they give you a
diamond that makes yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know but then you see that [ __ ]
and you're like how it it's um you know
you can afford diamonds that's the
tricky thing what kind of diamond is he
gonna buy any stretch do you ever know
how rich you are do i know how no no
people people think people think i have
like a like a comical amount of money
but they don't know about my all the
family members i've had to put in rehab
and all the random venmo requests i get
for new teeth
yeah this is covered a couple sets of
teeth just random people random people
family members you said though a couple
family members you know what close
family members are like they're
you're a kind person
thank you you're welcome
and you have great arms
can't take it
that is the most uncomfortable i've ever
been around a comedian i'm calling ronan
farrow
made eye contact with me and gave me a
compliment i'm triggered two compliments
you know what's funny is she took your
kind well but then you complimented her
look she [ __ ] broke that's what it
was i knew it was the look he went for
the arms he didn't go for the face he
didn't go for the body he just went arms
faithful guy compliments a woman yeah
you can't say you have a beautiful face
because you have a wife that's gonna be
like you're wearing shoes so he can't
see your foot yeah
are you a gambling woman
you want them to be uh well taken care
of but you don't want to [ __ ] them or
put them in your mouth no i don't like i
don't want to [ __ ] feet okay
do we know what that is yeah i don't
know if i want a [ __ ] feet
you flip it like that that's how you
make the butthole dude
it's even the juicy bro
my [ __ ] is also off white
so this makes perfect
wait a minute hold on a second that's
how you [ __ ] feet have you done that
because you're down to do weird [ __ ] i'm
down to do weird [ __ ] not because you
like it because you think the guy likes
it well yeah but if someone [ __ ] your
feet you might risk making you're not
gonna vote you're not on a boat right
now you're like doing the whole thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay